welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your house definition and you're now
locked into the channel where we've been
watching The Watchmen to break down
everything that you need to know about
the full season on HBO the season finale
is finally here and there's a hell of a
lot to unpack from it this has been one
of the best shows on TV this year and
the last episode definitely doesn't
disappoint throughout this video we'll
be going over the entire episodes plot
discussing all of the twists and turns
Easter eggs and giving our predictions
for the future there was some fan
theories that we got right some
completely left field and the show ended
on a huge cliffhanger that you're gonna
need dr. Manhattan's foresight to
predict but hey we're gonna try now
obviously there will be heavy spoilers
here so if you haven't had a chance to
watch the latest entry yet and don't
want to know what happens then I highly
suggest that you turn off now without
the way I just want to give a huge thank
you for clicking this video now let's
get into our breakdown of Watchmen
episode 9 okay so Watchmen episode 9
opens on the other side of the camera to
the Ozymandias speech to Robert Redford
as we know from the recording this was
the villain admitting to staging the
alien invasion in order to unite the
world in peace and he pretty much got
the actor elected as president due to
his power as we know the Utopia that he
wanted was never achieved and it's sad
seeing what it turned into
you also see Ozzie being filmed and
monitored by a Vietnamese crew and this
is a callback to the graphic novel even
down to the uniform which is worn by all
of his servants as we know from the
source material as he murdered all of
his staff by poisoning them so this is
actually taking place before the squid
attack the squid can be seen in a huge
tank behind Ozzie as well so yeah we
know this message was recorded before it
all went down we see a Vietnamese
cleaner breaking into his office and
going through his things on the desk is
an awesome anthias action figure which
was present in the graphic novel and his
computer is unlocked by the password
ramses ii which was how Dan and
Rorschach broke into it in his New York
office in the source material the
password hint is also untie not which is
a reference to the Gorton not which was
a knot that nobody could untie hence the
hint untie not Alexander the grade
actually managed
separated just by cutting it with his
sword and a knot is sort of a metaphor
for intractable problem solving by
coming up with a bold move that no one
would actually think to do because in
their mind they have real set in place
much like veidt's plan to stage an alien
attack this unlocks a fridge full of
sperm samples and on the test tube that
the cleaner picks out are the numbers 2
3 4 6 this may potentially be a nod to
the number 23 no not the terrible Jim
Carrey movie but the belief that 23 is a
significant number that is seen
throughout history at several important
moments 23 is well 23 and 46 is 23 times
2 so yeah I definitely think there might
be some way to that here
the woman inseminates herself and that's
the first band theory of the episode
confirmed true is the daughter of
Ozymandias so congratulations to
everyone who got that right we also
learned that Ozymandias never had sex
with a woman and this is sort of a
callback to the book in which Rorschach
states that he's possibly homosexual to
me though the character always came
across as asexual as he was fascinated
with historical figures such as
Alexander the Great who we actually see
on a painting hanging up in his office
there were also red apples beside the
image and you might remember from last
time that when John was young at the
castle he picked an apple out of a bowl
upon exploring the castle he then hid in
a cupboard and saw the original mr.
Phillips and Miss Crookshanks having sex
and this caused him to drop it not long
after he was given a Bible and shown a
picture of Adam and Eve who famously
took forbidden fruit portrayed in the
book as an apple and they lost their
innocence in doing so Jon dropping the
Apple also was the loss of his innocence
and the fact that apples appear here
once more makes me think that Ozzy -
similar to John now views the world in a
new light
we then jump to 2008 and see lady true
in what reminded me of the cover of John
Carpenter's movie the thing approaching
Karnak at this point all of ossie
servants are dead as we know he murdered
them and true refers to him as a
smartest man in the world which was a
nickname that he went by in the comics
true has inherited the position as
smartest woman in the world
and once more the watchman tips has
captured the idea of passing things on
this was a huge aesthetic with both the
original Nite Owl Silk Spectre Jett
Crawford's robe Angela's grandfather and
yet hero emerges once more
Redford hasn't returned Ozzy's calls and
as we saw last time he's been running
the squid fall we see that it's
automatic which also explains how it
kept running after he went to Europa
true wants to get rid of all new killer
weapons and she explains that she's
discovered that dr. Manhattan is on
Europa in order to do this true one to
take Doc's powers and she needs 42
billion dollars to do it
she divulges that she's aussies daughter
but yet he still turns it down anyway
this one thing to save the world by
killing someone kind of plays into trues
plan throughout the entire season and it
also reflects Ozzy's original plan in
some ways when talking to Ozzy true
discusses serpro which is traveling to
Europa and she also gives him the exact
time that it's going to arrive later
it's confirmed that the message that
Ozzy wrote on the surface of the Moon
was saved me daughter and not save me
dr. Manhattan and he says that he will
never call her daughter but yeah clearly
in this moment of need he did as he goes
over his origin story stating that he
started from nothing which is also a
line that's present in the graphic novel
we then jump once more to Ozzy on Europa
wearing his suit and an earthquake
begins as a craft lands outside we see
that using the horseshoe he's sure
shanked his way out of the cell and he
runs to true ship to get onboard as he
is shot out by the game warden but he
manages to catch the bullet a famous
trick that he did in the original
graphic novel he kills the game warden
revealing that he planned out the entire
thing even his imprisonment for his own
sanity hilariously the warden asks if he
was worthy and white says no but you put
on a hell of a show yeah and as we learn
from episode two and his overall plan
Ozzy loves putting on a show he ascends
into space and then is preserved by
being sprayed in gold from head to toe
so yet another fan Theory confirmed Ozzy
is actually encased in the golden statue
in truce for barium true purchased the
clocks form in Episode four because this
would be the landing zone of the ship
and yeah
as we guessed it he's been on the planet
since then true goes to tell beyond that
she is a clone of her mother which it
turns out she already knew probably
because of all in nostalgia she's been
pumped with as true stated she wanted
both her father and mother there to
witness her greatest achievement the
absorption of dr. Manhattan's powers the
millenium clock is activated and later
Veidt says the end is nigh which is a
reference to the sign that Rorschach
used to carry around in the graphic
novel true wears a hat that looks like a
halo perhaps indicating that she's an
angel or rather the angel of death but
it's also shots of crucifixes in this
episode which highlights to me that she
believes she is a God true is sort of
been and villain this entire time well
it's so of like similar to Ozzy she's a
Belen Bert she wants to do well I
suppose yeah but it's very complex and
yet true it's definitely a complex
person you also pass the newsstand and a
headline can be seen that pays lip
service to the fact that there's still
civil unrest in Vietnam the vendor says
that no one cares about what happened to
Ozzy and as we know from the first
episode he was declared dead but it's
clear that the public have their own
theories we then cut the cavalry HQ and
see Senator Joe Kean senior for the
first time for those who don't know in
the graphic novel he actually outlawed
vigilantes with the Keene act and this
is why the Watchmen had to give up their
lives as superheroes he's a cyclops
member and we also hear the other side
of the Angela a bar battle with the
cavalry lookingglass walks over to her
and yet theory confirmed he took the
mask off someone else and snuck into the
headquarters doc is transported to a
cage and yet another theory confirmed
he's not dead well not yet we'll talk
about a lair anyway the cage is made of
lithium which is able to contain him and
Laurie says John which is acknowledgment
of their relationship it turns out that
Keene and Co are angered about Redford
taking away their guns and for making
them bear white guilt he also says that
during the white night doc didn't
actually kill the attacker that broke
into their home and instead he
transported them to New Mexico most
notably Gila flats which is actually the
location that John became trapped in the
science experiment that turned him into
a god they realized Angela and cow were
hiding the secret and sent injured to
play the long game in order to get close
to them Joe even wears similar underwear
and yet Lori just laughs at it Angela
shows up and says that true is actually
planning something bigger and as she's
smarter than they are they don't really
stand a chance she says that all of the
equipment and materials that they have
are from true and uh she's in their
systems Keene still gets in the cage and
yeah I have a bad feeling about this the
machine is set off which sends out a
blast causing ear ringing and people to
vomit Detective Comics 27 can also be
seen which was the first appearance of
Batman Batman often refers to the death
of his parents as the night his will
then neared and will to gives a nod to
this later in the episode when
discussing his own origin story in Tulsa
it turns out that true actually
transported the cage and those around it
and we can see that they are now in the
square where the new stand was using her
forces she disarms the cavalry soldiers
and the machine has started up which
sucks all of the powers out doc Adrien
also refers to Laurie as mr. Sir Peck
which was her original name at the end
of the graphic novel Laurie went into
hiding and changed her identity but it's
nice that as he still refers to her as
how he originally knew the character it
turns out that Jo was liquefied during
the transference and doc looks at the
blood which snaps him out of apathy and
reminds him that he needs to actually do
something which we'll get into in just a
bit
true reveals that she chose to transfer
them to this area because it's where the
Greenwood rice massacre took place and
it's time for them to die wiping out all
of the cavalry not long after she also
refers to Doc is the big blue cheese
which to me was a reference to Shazam
who often gets called the big red cheese
doc now quote-unquote awake transports
Laurie lookingglass
and Ozzy to Karnak and Looking Glass
vomits again this is another nice little
callback to the graphic novel in which
Laurie used to always vomit after
teleporting Angela asked her why he
didn't take her out there - and he says
it's because he didn't want to die alone
now last time there was a lot of people
wondering why doc just didn't get out of
the way of the gun especially as he knew
it was coming but you have to understand
that the character can only see what's
going to happen he can't change here
because then yeah all that he sees
before and all that he sees after it
that won't happen
it's it's difficult to get your head
around the whole doc thing and how
you've used time but he's sort of just a
passenger that's forced to go through
the motion
and this is why he doesn't move here he
basically has no free will he just has
to watch her play out
he also says too true he can raise the
temperature if she's cold and this may
be a reference at the graphic novel in
which Janey Slater gets a chair from how
inhumane that he is and he thinks it's
caused by the temperature and not
because she's scared
anyway true activates the clock and this
sucks out all of his powers and life
force and Angela begs him to stay she
asked where he is and in a really
heartbreaking scene he says that he's in
every moment that they're together all
at once he transforms to the form that
she fell in love with before it ends
thrusting Angela back it's really sad
watching what could be the characters
death and his power goes into the clock
being transformed into something that
true can absorb we know that this is
what caused the death of keen as he
didn't process the power properly so
true is taking these steps in Carnac as
he launches the squid fall which is now
frozen to destroy the machine as he
knows that true won't save the world
because he sees too much of himself in
her and realizes his own failings though
he never confirms it using the phone
with a contact Angela and tell her to
get in the booth as the machine and true
are destroyed this is where the crucifix
is seen just as she's about to become a
god and yeah it's just awesome seen the
character killed at the last second
as you say that this I'll have a
five-mile radius and possibly
inadvertently caused a lot of deaths
which may down the line need humanity
once more to believe that aliens are
still attacking Angela flees the area
using a shield and runs the dreamland
theater where will is waiting for her he
also has Angela's children and is
positioning mirrors the first episode in
which she watched a film about bass
Reeves they talked about how you can't
heal under a mask and it's a brilliant
exchange that feels like a satisfying
conclusion that sort of brings
everything full circle showing why will
took the path in life that he did will
in says that you can't make an omelet
without breaking a couple of eggs and
says that dr. Manhattan told him to pass
this on to Angela this plays back to
when Angela grabbed a box of eggs and
smashed them off the floor and if you
watched are what happens next prediction
video then you'll know that we drew some
attention to these and upon returning
home Angela finds an unbroken egg now
you will remember last time that Doc
said that he was able to transfer his
powers and this has brought a back year
what could be happening in the second
season anyway we'll get into that in
just a bit but at carnac Ozzie Leeds
Laurie and looking-glass - Archie which
is the ship that the Watchmen used in
the original graphic novel as he says
that it was buried in the ice and this
is because night owl and Rorschach
crashed it before making their walk to
Karnak Laurie and looking-glass then
arrest Ozzie for the genocide that he
committed saying that the world won't
end it will just carry on and this kind
of leads me to believe that Laurie
didn't tell the truth at the end of the
comic I will fear that it would destroy
the world we know that this fear also
United the world and she thinks that
it's time to break out of this and move
forward with the population knowing the
truth anyway back at the home angela
discovers the egg and goes to the pool
at the dock told her that she needed to
see him on as it would be important
later and she like eats the egg raw and
walks out to see if she can walk on
water and just as she's about to put a
foot down we cut to black ending the
season on a massive cliffhanger so does
she have the powers of a god well I
personally believe that she does the doc
doesn't tend to joke around and he isn't
misleading for the sake of it so
personally I don't think that he would
have one told her she needs to see him
on the pool and to tell well about the
eggs if this wasn't purposely put there
to know that she can do this
secondly I also don't think that the doc
is dead in episode 8 he did say on Mars
that there was a duplicate of him and
just going through the motions almost
robotically so potentially the one in
the cage that we saw this entire time
it could just be a fake dr. Manhattan
doc can also see the past and future of
his own life and thus in order to let
Angela know that the pool and eggs were
important he would need to know the
outcome of this which would mean that he
would have to be alive in the future I
personally believe that Angela will get
his powers and the doc will re-emerge
once more his energy was also never
transferred it was just stored in the
Machine and thus he could still be out
there
he told Angela exactly what she needed
to hear in order to go out into the pool
and thus this death that he went through
actually has a causality to it there's a
lot to think about but personally I
think all the clues are there and if we
get the second season and you
I hope this is all answered I'm just
double just praying we get that second
season now obviously I'd love to hear
your thoughts on this finale and what
you thought of the season as a whole
comment below and let me know and if you
enjoy this video then please give it a
thumbs up and I just want to give a huge
thank you to everyone who's checked out
the breakdowns over the whole season
I really really appreciate you being
here to watch them and yeah just make
sure you stay locked to the channel for
a couple more watchmen related
breakdowns dropping over the next few
weeks if not then have an awesome new
year and yeah just cheers for all the
support we also do a podcast called
watching The Watchmen in which we break
down the original graphic novel issue by
issue so if you want to know the full
backstory of the book then make sure you
check it out after this if you want to
come chat to me after the video that
make sure you follow me on twitter at
definition whitey or head over to my
discord server which will be linked in
the description below we drop videos on
there early so if you want to see stuff
before anyone else and that's the best
place to be it's free to join and we
have an awesome community so hopefully I
see you over there very soon we're also
giving away a free copy of Joker which
is one of our favorite movies of the air
and all you have to do to be in with the
chance of winning is like the video make
sure you subscribe to the channel and
leave your thoughts and watchman in the
comment section below the one is gonna
be chosen on the 15th of January and the
set will be shipped out from then to
forget surprise it's the best of luck to
everyone who takes part this is a
channel for people who are super into
superheroes so if that's the kind of
thing you like it subscribe thank you
for taking the time to watch this I've
been definition you've been the best
I'll see you next time take care peace